bernard vous êtes survivalistes alors
survivalisme le survivalisme c'est un
mode de vie qui permet d'évaluer
d'anticiper les risques liés à notre
environnement
vous dites pour vous que le coran
navires us c'est pire qu'une épidémie
c'est quoi alors déjà je pense qu'il
faut revenir à la base le coronavirus
c'est une pandémie pourquoi parce que
c'est juste présent sur tous les
continents c'est partout dans le monde
dans l'instant on a commencé à avoir au
minimum une centaine de cas sur un autre
continent
c'était une pandémie c'est juste c'est
vrai ce qu'il avait déclaré c'est tout
ben officiellement la nouvelle d'hier
n'ose pas le dire mais c'est vrai que ça
veut dire mais les 40e rugissants la
position de lecture où les petits mots
logiquement l'épidémie ça veut dire dans
la maison des autres la pandémie ça veut
dire chez nous partout donc oui c'est le
monde est là et la ilaha illa peu raison
alors vous dites que ça va augmenter de
mois en mois alors effectivement je
pense que là on est arrivés à une phase
qui est comme une charnière c'est à dire
que quand on commence à voir une une
stabilisation entre guillemets de
l'augmentation du nombre de cas en chine
notamment
mais comme ça commence à se déclarer
sérieusement dans nos pays et un dans
d'autres pays on va effectivement avoir
une augmentation du nombre de cas ça
c'est une certitude
d'accord alors vous encore un militant à
quoi vous vous préparer bah justement à
ceux à la fin du monde non non pas du
tout ça c'est typiquement ce que disent
les journalistes parce que sa fiche de
nos jours perth a fait cesser du
sensationnalisme oui c'est ça oui alors
vous la peur que ça arrive est toujours
inférieure à la déception que ça
n'arrive pas c'est vrai j'ai envie de
vous dire j'ai envie de vous dire que
oui non mais c'est pas faux mais au
passage c'est quand même un peu la
meilleure chance de l'humanité aussi que
ça arrive c'est pas méchant mais c'est
non mais j'aime pas les gens qui sont
enfermés dans leur 2 cv des gens qui ont
fermé dans leur futur me font encore
plus ce alors pourquoi vous pourquoi
vous dites que la fin du mois
la fin du monde c'est la meilleure chose
qui pouvait à qui peut arriver à
l'humanité on va prendre que l'indiqué
on faire flipper un nom mais on va
apprendre d'eux m'avait prévenu qu'ils
soient ramenés c'est patrick sébastien
c'est pas les infos extrêmement on sait
que à la population mondiale
arrivé un stade d'environ neuf milliards
d'habitants
on sera au maximum on n'en est pas très
loin on a un peu plus de 7 milliards oui
bon
depuis des années je prêche pour une
régression
il ya un contrôle de la population
mondiale atteindra ventures avec thor
qui claque des doigts
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cas depuis des années donc je
prêche pour une réduction de la
population mondiale parce que justement
on a des ressources qui sont finies et
comme notre consommation de ressources
elle elle le fait qu augmenter par
rapport tout simplement au nombre du mat
il ya sur terre un jour
clairement on va l'avoir dans l'os on
voit réduit comment un réduit comment et
bien justement je pense que c'est au
gouvernement ou aux états de prendre le
problème à bras le corps et de dire bon
bah voilà maintenant on va demander on
va faire une politique par exemple comme
pu faire la chine pendant des années où
on va dire aux gens bah on fait pas
peut-être x enfants mais on va en faire
peut-être que un salaire voire empêché
d'avoir l'épidémie ben non non non non
non parce que je veux dire par là ce que
je veux dire par là c'est aujourd'hui le
plus gros problème de la terre quoi
qu'on en pense c'est quand même plus
humain donc si on se charge pas de
régler le problème nous mêmes la terre
va se charger de le faire ou alors le
renard c'est la démographie
oui c'est effectivement l'un des
problèmes c'est la démographie
gouverneur bernard vous dites que le
premier encore un navire russe fait de
plus en plus important vous dites qu'il
faut préparer ce mois ci au plus faut
préparer son sac d'évacuation c'est le
ressac d'évacuation ça vous l'avez votre
sac d'évacuation wathelet alors qu'est
ce qu'il a à pâques et chief dedans
j'aurais bien aimé avoir juste ça mais
alors dites nous ce qui alors c'est quoi
ce sac d'évacuation alors pour ce soir
pourquoi ce sac d'évacuation garde sa
sincère dans des occasions qui on va
dire son qu'on rencontre plus souvent
dans nos contrées basiquement une
inondation un incendie ces tableaux de
repartir chez toi rapidement parce que
c'est le bazar
ce que vous pensez qu'il va y aller il
va en avoir de plus en plus ce n'est des
cas comme ça oui il ya de fortes chances
pour vous dormez avec votre sac
il n'est pas loin non ios d'accord vous
venez juste pourquoi vous auriez droit
vous de vous je vais pas les autres
sages comprend parier tout le monde à
l'horizon d'un site ou d'un droit on
restera toujours avec deux barres
conçois qu'on soit bien clair c'est pas
forcément dans le cas d'une pandémie
lâche parle d'un accident on va dire
plus banal qui arrive tous les ans en
france
un incendie une inondation c'est des
trucs qu'on voit tous les ans regardez
cet hiver c'est encore arrivé il ya des
gens qui n'ont qu'une maison avait bien
sûr le but là le but avec ça c'est de
sauver sa peau dans l'urgence tu arrives
tu attrapes ta paire de chaussures tu
attrapes ton sac et tu tombes pour vous
n'en voit que ça que vous avez du
matériel ya quoi de quoi s'abriter
de quoi faire du feu de quoi récolter
purifier de l'eau de quoi se nourrir à
boire et à manger vous avez quoi comme
manger volontat c'était parce que des
conduites céder à la rescousse et le
laisser dans la valade minuit passé
minuit les dans la vague s'est déplacé
du vivre ensemble
ce sont des plats lyophilisés par
exemple ou des rations d'urgence
d'accord vous vous pensez qu'il va y
avoir un scénario catastrophe il ya moi
je pense il faut aujourd'hui on a un
problème et je pense qu'effectivement il
peut potentiellement il y en avoir une
notamment avec le coronavirus ce que
vous dites ou six rencontres le virus
ebola
ouais c'est la fin du monde ben il ya
actuellement une épidémie d'ebola qui
sévit en république démocratique du
congo
ouais je te laisse imaginer cyril si la
grille à la souche du coronavirus y
rencontrer bola tout ça ça ce mix parce
que ça les virus mutent on obtient plus
de neige qui se consomme et donc oui on
obtient la cage aux ruses et on obtient
la contagiosité du coronavirus qui est
d'au moins 50 fois la grippe et la
mortalité des mollahs la mortalité de la
souche des mollahs actuelle c'est 60% en
oeuvre des scénarios comme ça non mais
bon ça c'est du niveau d'un oscar à
hollywood la soupe des schtroumpfs mais
maintenant elle va voir rien on crée
passable au silence alors que ça ne
tient pas du congo actuellement au congo
ce qui s'est passé une épidémie de
rougeole et la rougeole a plus tu es que
ebola dans le pays ont fait beaucoup de
fantasmes vis-à-vis des bolas à tuer
mais ils ont un autre problème pour
lequel on a une vague d'annoncés mémo
ebola
bernard nous donne son sentiment c'est
pas la peine d'être à l'heure contre lui
non plus bien la remercie d'être là je
voudrais l'application scientifique est
ce que c'est possible que des ja d'île
en île n ont cessé de mécanismes de
maladies complètement différent il ya
une maladie par voie aérienne une
maladie à transmission contact c'est des
virus très différent d'accord bernard la
mutation parce que c'est beau c'est
nationaux moi non un virus elle peut
prendre une dimension dramatique
la mutation du virus alors pour
l'instant la surveillance montrent que
le virus n'a pas muté du tout mais
évidemment tous les virus respiratoires
on les surveille avec cette histoire de
mutation mais il faut bien dire que pour
l'instant à chaque fois on se fait un
peu peur c'est souvent très rassurant et
ça n'impacte pas beaucoup sur l'épidémie
alors quand il est intéressant au plan
scientifique et technique merci d'avancé
c'est moi par là bernard surplus il est
venu pour ça il est venu pour témoigner
bernard est ce que vous possédez des
armes vous dit ouais mais ça c'est quand
vous avez des armes pourquoi vous avez
dit bah ça sert à avoir à manger tout
simplement d'accord c'est quoi comme
arme un fusil tout simplement un accord
avec angola d'accord et au cas où donc
vous vous habitez ou moi j'suis en
bourgogne
d'accord vous habitez dans une dans un
appart tranquille alors je suis dans un
petit village vont à d'accord et vous
habitez ou dans une dans une maison une
maison d'accord et vous vous préparez à
tout moment à la fin du monde ou pas du
tout le non pas du tout en fait faut pas
voir ça comme ça c'est juste que par
exemple je passe avec un truc tout bête
demain tu au supermarché tu fais tes
courses par exemple tu as besoin d'une
boîte de petits pois
malik dans une boîte de conserve bah oui
dans pendule moi je vais en prendre deux
mais c'est une simple amende honorable
commandes et une zone inondable là où
vous habitez
non justement ce que c'est une zone
inondable est ce qu'il ya une forêt à
côté il peut y avoir un feu j'ai
justement du jus oasis point de chute de
manière bien précise
parce que je suis pas inondable d'accord
pas y avoir un feu de forêt bien bien la
maison devait pas voir un feu de forêt
c'est ça bernard a en tout cas vers le
rap a brûlé ma maison d'accord donc non
mais c'est important vous voyez ce qu'il
a il a choisi j'ai choisi le lieu mais
pas de manière et des enfants meurent là
vous avez une femme non donc vous êtes
seul j'ai un champ d'accord
bon hé hé vous allez souvent sofreco
vrai votre nom avec des amis tout
simplement
d'accord d'accord donc très bien vous
êtes plusieurs comme ça se dire voilà
que vous êtes prêts à vivre le pire bas
en tout cas que ça peut arriver une
situation d'urgence peut arriver oui on
nous dit toujours que on essaye toujours
en fait basiquement les journalistes
nous font passer toujours pour des
andouilles nous font passer pour des
fous on voit bien les réactions ce soir
on nous dit toujours par exemple ouais
ça sert à rien ça sert à rien c'est
comme le masque à gaz sarin way sofa
moment là mais s'il n'avait pas fait
d'enfants c'est parce que vous avez pas
rencontré la femme de votre vie parce
que vous avez peur de l'avenir
ah non c'est parce que j'ai pas
rencontré la femme de ma vie c'est
complètement différent ça n'a rien à
voir
vous feriez deux hommes face à wigan
mais c'est une bonne question on videra
sa lancée ça n'a rien à voir là c'est
karim zéribi lacets mythiques
ça n'a rien à voir avec non c'est parce
que j'ai pas trouvé la bonne personne
pour palabrer verte voilà la cobas est
revenu hanter la démographie mondiale si
vous trouvez la fabri oui d'accord et en
cas d'incendié ou la souveraine
également où partirais pas bien sur les
arêtes sac à dos d'âne bien sûr bernard
vous dit et on va revenir sur cette
phrase parce qu'on en a parlé hier ya un
instant vous dites mine de rien qu'un
scénario catastrophe qui aurait la
meilleure chance pour la planète et
l'humanité
oui parce que nos campagnes à sa
population à cette population mondiale
donc vous vous espérez à un scénario
catastrophe ou pas non même si vous êtes
sur ce que vous seriez ne souhaite pas
la mort des gens soit je souhaite c'est
qu'on puisse juste s'en sortir parce
qu'actuellement on voit bien qu'on a
on est au début d'une crise écologique
majeure on pollue tout notre
environnement
les sous sols l'eau l'air c'est vrai on
urbanisé à outrance et c'est pour ça
qu'on a des inondations comme m on a
quand même de plus en plus de sécheresse
avec des incendies plus ou moins
spectaculaires mais exemple l'australie
l'amazonie un tueur de truc cela est
vrai mais ça je suis d'accord avec lui
mais d'après moi je vais vous dire un
truc vous regardez bernard comme un nul
hubert lui 1
mais mine de rien on voit depuis
quelques années des very phénomène qu'on
ne voyait jamais avant donc donc
forcément c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même
des règlements il ya des choses qui
arrivent
on les voyait pas je suis désolé même en
france il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'inondations il ya jamais eu onze corps
aujourd'hui il ya une tempête on n'avait
pas au plan paris on croyait voilà ça ça
arrive jamais et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des règlements non
seulement climatique
mais c'est vrai que dans le monde entier
on voit qu'il ya des choses qui s'est
produit alors qu'ils se produisaient
perdre a expliqué ça non mais il ajoute
une dimension il presque une dimension
mystique parce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure la terre va se venger il ya ce
côté sur les phénomènes ils sont on ne
peut pas nier c'est nous qui dit parle
parle en accion l'économie bernard mais
de là à espérer un scénario catastrophe
qui les sert pas on espère qu'il
espérait qu'une seule chose non non mais
la seule chose qu'il faut dire c'est que
cette vision d'une urgence c
millénariste vers la fin du monde arrive
hélas le sentiment de vivre des choses
qui n'ont jamais eu lieu et qui sont
exceptionnels on retrouve ça dans toute
l'histoire de l'humanité à toutes les
époques des choses qui viennent de nulle
part qui sont inexplicables et qu'on n'a
jamais vécu avant c'est toute l'histoire
de l'humanité et là c'est vrai que c'est
ce mouvement là qui datent des 60
étaient invités inventé c'est l'herbe
pour la peur la peur de l'immigration
qui on a deux pas quitter et la peur de
la menace nucléaire
il ya toujours des nouvelles peurs qui
font que les survivalistes auront
toujours un avenir et ce sont des gens
qui à mon avis partagent la même
morbidité que ceux qui sont toujours
tournés vers le passé
ils sont enfermés dans le futur mais
c'est pas mieux dans mes débuts je monte
des ressources de la paix ça c'est
vraiment parce que pourquoi je dis ça
mine de rien aujourd'hui moi je vous dis
j'ai vu trois quatre personnes
il ya plein de gens qui me disent
acheter jure je crois que là on arrive à
la fin du monde avec les coronavirus les
événements climatiques qu'on voit donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui le
disons en déconnant voilà au second
degré mais mine de rien c'est quelque
chose qu'on entend beaucoup plus
maintenant qu'on entendait avant yahia
voilà quelques ya quelques années donc
voila et max mitau 6110 pour sortir
l'espagnol 60 millions de morts
by cyril vous lisez la correspondance
des écrivains en 1918 c'est à la virgule
près j'aurais dû vous apportez des
textes espagne avec tamedia de dire
qu'on est de plus en plus sur terre il
ya de moins en moins à bouffer permet
l'expression que c'est une vérité bien
sûr j'allais volvo problème c'est la
plaie d'écologie pour cela parce que
larry sinon on va seul à monter
éternellement
c'est une chasse et au niveau mondial
pas seulement au niveau mondial au
niveau de chaque pays oui vraiment on
agit la france pour arrêter moi c'est
comme accolades et réseaux et mais je
vais vous dire quelque chose et paco
l'anneau la france à notre petite
échelle
arrêtez avec ça l'horrible mais sauf que
bien évidemment mais il faut faire effet
de levier
que dit on achète des produits oui on
reporte nos pollutions sur les autres
pays oui mais faut faire faut faire
levier nicolas dupont aignan y vous déjà
faisant levier avec d'associations déjà
aux grandes nations
je vous le dis la place est encore une
grande action pas alors nommé nom vient
évidemment mais en revanche il faut
peut-être pas en termes écologie avec
eux et isolée pour aller [ __ ]
pollution là bas et pas la france qui va
avec joly c'est pas la france qui va
sauver le monde
ça je vous le dis d'accord car il est
bernard je voulais vous poser une
question est ce que vous êtes totalement
fatalistes face à la situation
ou est-ce que vous vous imaginez qu'on
puisse encore changer de paradigme et
est ce que vous faites quelque chose
pour ça ou à ce que finalement vous n'y
croyez pas les choses pourront pas
changer justement je pense que ça peut
tout à fait chaud la brame aaa et j'y
travaille tous les jours pour ça et j'en
suis pas le seul
il y a
différents individus qui font comme moi
moi par exemple j'essaye de limiter au
maximum mon empreinte carbone dans
certaines choses par exemple sur ma
nourriture jeu j'essaye d'en cultiver un
maximum dans mon jardin d'accord je mets
pas dans 30 chimiques je fais de la
permaculture
ça fait cinq ans maintenant que la ccm
farfelu c'est sûr et après je voudrais
dire ici me bernard je trouve bernard
que vous êtes vous êtes beaucoup moins
d'investir et fantaisiste que ce
contentieux on peut l'on peut le penser
voilà je vous le dis je voudrais juste
en fait répondre à une question qui m'a
été posée tout à l'heure ivy vous avez
posé une question m'intrigue et
j'aimerais y répondre et christine kelly
ex ocs ah oui on a donné 3 où il a donné
trois millions d'euros à ces anneaux
pamarot scène c'est en fait non je
n'espère pas une catastrophe parce que
je ne souhaite pas la mort des gens
néanmoins faut bien penser que si jamais
quelque chose comme ça devait arriver
demain ce serait une chance entre
guillemets pour la planète dans mon sens
écologique du terme je parle parce que
ça réduire est fatalement la
consommation donc la pause la pollution
mais ce serait aussi une chance pour
l'humanité parce que ça ne permettrait
de caen dira d'atteindre entre
guillemets un espèce de nouvel âge d'or
je sais pas si on peut dire ça comme ça
qui nous ferait en tout cas plus nous
interroger nous faire nous faire faire
des introspections pour se dire
maintenant on a fait des erreurs qu'on
ne la réduisent ont pas à prenons notre
passé et faisons se poser la question
mais je ne sais pas c'est pas mondiale
ce conte à 7 milliards à peu près un peu
plus de 7 milliards voilà de population
mondiale pendant deux ans également via
réparer comme ça mais il ya des études
sérieuses qui ont été faites ou ils
disent que c'est la veille le rapport à
la population mondiale actuelle c'est la
moitié
il savait en dehors du fameux
coronavirus mais il ya j'ai découvert ça
très récemment on en parle très peu dans
les médias
un drame écologique en afrique avec ses
milliards de sauterelles en train de
piller plus à ressources de l'afrique de
l'est est dramatique verbatim est
absolument à c'est des choses qu'on
voyait pas en parlera pourquoi chez nous
parce qu'on n'est pas concerné bien sûr
s'ils sont les lois c'est moi c'est
comme aux débuts des russes avec la
chine ça veut dire que là ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut se lamenter mais qu'il
faut absolument changer de modèle mais
on est tous convaincus mais
paradoxalement il ya une inertie
incroyable et votre métier berna oui moi
j'y travaillais à bas loyer bas il est
dj fait la fête
moi je suis en fait la gestion des
entreprises et notamment en logistique
mère c'était oberlin dans la vie parce
que huawei mais ce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est vrai que c'est tournez manège où
ces btp là il est célibataire nouveau
coach sa survie si la survie vraiment
une vie parce que c'est vrai les onze
est heureux bernard ah oui on est
carrément parce que en fait mon chat
noir ne pense pas à la survie tous les
jours je pense d'abord fait le fur moi
je suis heureux quand je suis dans mon
jardin en pitié mon jardin j'ai aucun
problème avec ça mais que faire alors
yann moix je parlais de la liberté
individuelle et du civisme bailly il est
libre de fait nos mails en vidéo du
monde qui est difficile à voir ce jeu de
la main mais je suis dit je veux la
vérité me bernard didelot rend ça y est
célibataire mais gagner mais je veux
dire le conseil est célibataire et à la
sac à dos le problème c'est beau ça peut
ça peut se faire
bernard en tout cas je voulais vous dire
et on est assez d'accord ici bernard il
a pas dit que dès que des jeunes ont
certainement pas au lit merci bernard
[Applaudissements]